.
* Dumpfe, spannungsvolle Klänge *
Ein Notruf auf der Monte Rosa Hütte
für Bergretter Richard Lehner.
Ich bin auf Heli FK.
Zwei Bergsteiger sind abgestürzt.
Die Italiener versuchten auch schon
ranzukommen, aber es klappte nicht.
Jetzt muss die Rettungscrew
aus Zermatt zu Hilfe kommen -
bei Windböen von über 100 km/h.
(Mann über Funk) Challenging, was?
(Über Funk)
Es sind schwierige Windverhältnisse.
Alfa, Kontakt.
Die Opfer sind schwer zu erreichen.
Von unten geht es gar nicht.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
"Hoch hinaus" -
über Menschen und ihre Leidenschaft
in den Schweizer Bergen.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Dynamische, perlende Musik *
Zwei Tage zuvor, auf der Monte Rosa
Hütte mitten in den Walliser Alpen.
Richard Lehner ist hier Hüttenwart.
Bergretter ist sein Nebenjob.
Jetzt in der Sommersaison
ist er fast immer hier oben.
Tagsüber
fällt es einem nicht so auf,
aber die Stimmung am Abend und
am frühen Morgen ist immer grandios.
In dieser Augustwoche hat er zu-
sätzlich Pikettdienst als Bergretter.
Er muss rund um die Uhr
mit einem Notruf rechnen.
Dies trotz normalem Hüttenalltag.
Jaro, Salat?
Wie viele Köpfe?
(Hochdeutsch) Wie viele Köpfe?
- Du kannst sieben nehmen.
Zusätzlich führt er
auch noch ein Hotel unten in Zermatt,
ist Bergführer und hat eine Familie.
Da es eine absehbare Zeit ist ...
In rund einem Monat
bzw. in fünf Wochen
ist die Hütte geschlossen.
Dann herrscht wieder
ein anderer Rhythmus.
Daher müssen wir nicht immer ...
... mehr als 100 % geben.
Es ist 10.30 Uhr,
die ersten Gäste treffen ein.
* Handyklingeln *
Ja, hier ist Richi. Tschau.
Gut, dann geht's in den Einsatz.
Ich mache mich bereit.
Tschüss, tschau-tschau.
Es geht in den Einsatz.
Wir fliegen
für eine Evakuation aufs Dirruhorn.
Also Bergsteiger, die festsitzen?
- Ja, genau.
Sie kommen nicht mehr weiter,
sind zu erschöpft
oder die Verhältnisse
sind zu schwierig.
Ich habe etwa 6-7 Min. Zeit,
bis der Helikopter hier ist.
Dann geht's los.
Ich bin auf Heli FK.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Die alpinen Rettungen laufen
im Wallis über die Air Zermatt.
Die Zentrale
hat auch den Bergretter alarmiert.
Pilot ist Robert Andenmatten.
(Frau über Funk)
Bei der Bordierhütte
könnt ihr
eine Zwischenlandung machen.
Zuerst muss sich das Rettungsteam
einen Überblick verschaffen.
Sind sie wohl
hier hinten auf diesem Grat?
Sie müssten fast
in gerader Linie vor uns sein.
Die genaue Position der Bergsteiger
ist unklar.
Hier ist nichts.
Sie müssen
auf der anderen Seite sein.
Sie müssten hier unten sein.
Hier unten.
- Ah, da sind sie.
Unten am Felsaufschwung
sind die Bergsteiger kurz sichtbar.
Für die Crew ist klar:
Es braucht eine Rettung aus der Luft.
(Computerstimme) 100 feet.
- Richi ist angehängt.
Richard Lehner als Bergspezialist
wird an die Seilwinde angehängt.
Kufen raus.
Eins, zwei, drei, Richi.
Und dann soll er
zu ihnen hinuntergelassen werden.
Die Bergsteiger sitzen
auf einem kleinen Felsvorsprung.
Der Pilot muss Richard Lehner
an der Absturzstelle absetzen.
Winde ab.
- Winde läuft.
(Mann) Richi ist unter den Kufen.
Achtest du auf die Höhe?
Dann prüfst du das Ganze vorn.
Ist das okay?
8 m.
(Computerstimme) Check height.
- 3 ...
... 2 ...
- Achtung.
... 1 m.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
So, jetzt lassen wir ihn
langsam runter.
Entlasten, genau.
Wie geht's?
- Der erste Teil hat geklappt.
Beide Bergsteiger sind unverletzt,
aber die Frau hat Magenprobleme.
Sie und ihr Partner sind morgens
von der Bordierhütte aus gestartet.
Die Frau hat ein paar Stunden später
Bauchschmerzen bekommen,
dann Durchfall, dann Erbrechen.
Jetzt sei sie zu schwach,
um weiterzugehen.
Du sicherst dich hier, okay?
Gut, Robi, der Patient ist bereit.
Du bleibst sitzen.
Für mich ist es so okay.
6 m ...
... 5, 4 ...
... 3, 2, 1 m. Kontakt.
Die Frau wird als Erste ausgeflogen.
Dann passiert etwas,
womit der Retter nicht gerechnet hat.
(Frau, panisch)
Nein, nein! Nein, bitte nicht!
Winde ab. Winde auf.
Die Frau hat Angst,
doch es muss schnell gehen.
Sie hatte ziemlich grosse Angst.
Bergsteigen ist das Eine,
Hunderte Meter über dem Abgrund
hängen etwas anderes.
Ja, tipptopp.
Ui, ui, ui.
Die Frau
wird auf dem Gletscher abgesetzt.
Winde auf.
- Winde läuft. Eine super Sache.
Jetzt wird auch
ihr Kletterpartner ausgeflogen.
Ich nehme sie an die Kufen.
Da der Gerettete Steigeisen trägt,
kann er nicht in den Heli hinein
und muss auf den Kufen bleiben.
Richard Lehner als Bergretter
ist für die Sicherheit der Personen
verantwortlich.
Das Heikle ist der erste Moment,
in dem man beurteilen muss,
wen man zuerst rettet, ob man
die Person an die Winde hängen kann,
ob der Wind für den Piloten
nicht zu stark ist
und wie viele Personen
transportiert werden können.
All diese Dinge
besprechen wir während des Einsatzes
und setzen sie dann gleich um.
Aber es musste sein.
Die Frau kommt in ein Spital,
ihr Begleiter wird ins Tal geflogen.
Für Richard Lehner
und den Piloten Robert Andenmatten
ist die Bergung damit abgeschlossen.
Ich kriege später
meist eine Rückmeldung
zum medizinischen Zustand
der Geretteten.
So können wir etwas daraus lernen.
So ist es.
Schlimmere Dinge,
v.a. Unfälle mit Kindern,
darf man
nicht zu nah an sich ranlassen.
Wir hatten mal einen gemeinsamen
Einsatz auf dem Gornergletscher,
der uns lange
in Erinnerung geblieben ist.
Eine Familie ging über den Gletscher
und ein Gletschertisch stürzte ein.
Er klemmte das Kind ein.
Der Grossvater ging voraus
und der Bub hinter ihm wurde
von einem grossen Stein eingeklemmt.
Der Bub ist nachher verstorben.
Man kann es sich nicht aussuchen.
- Nein.
- Es ist immer schwierig.
* Melancholische Klänge *
Auf der Hütte sind unterdessen
die ersten Wanderer angekommen.
Etwa 4 Std. dauert der Aufstieg
von der Gornergratbahn.
Der Wandereranteil in der Hütte
steigt stetig.
Nicht alle
haben viel alpine Erfahrung.
Ging es gut auf dem Gletscher?
War es das erste Mal?
Nein, aber das erste Mal allein.
- Das erste Mal allein?
Wir haben die Ausbildung gemacht
und waren nun zum ersten Mal allein.
Wie kamt ihr
mit den Steigeisen zurecht?
Gut, es ist etwas anders,
beinahe aper.
Ja, es ist aper.
Man sieht alle Spalten.- Genau.
Wir unterhalten den Weg immer gut.
Wir bringen Markierungen an
und sorgen dafür,
dass die Leute
den Weg auch im Nebel gut finden.
Wenn man Grunderfahrung hat,
kann man das auch gut allein machen,
wie diese Frauen hier.
* Lebhafte, perlende Musik *
Richard Lehner
führt die Hütte zusammen
mit seinem Freund Kilian Emmenegger.
Dieser übernimmt, wenn er
als Bergretter unterwegs ist.
Brechen viele frühmorgens auf?
- Das weiss ich noch nicht.
Es ist eine kleinere Gruppe, was?
- Es sind viele kleine Gruppen.
Ich denke schon,
dass morgen diverse aufbrechen.
Sind alle Zimmer besetzt?
Nein, zwei sind noch frei.
Acht Personen arbeiten auf der Hütte.
Das ist eine endlose Geschichte:
der Abwasch.
Jedes Mal, wenn man denkt,
man hätte es geschafft,
beginnt es wieder von vorn.
Das geht bis 22 Uhr so weiter.
Dies ist natürlich
eine der grösseren SAC-Hütten.
Was die Übernachtungszahlen
betrifft,
sind wir immer
unter den ersten vier oder fünf.
Wir haben zwischen
6'000 und 7'000 Übernachtungen.
Das führt beinahe
zu einem 20-Std.-Betrieb.
Bis die Letzten im Bett sind,
ist es 23 Uhr,
und um 1 Uhr stehen
die Ersten bereits wieder auf.
Dafür benötigt man Personal.
Heutzutage kann man von den Leuten
nicht mehr verlangen,
dass sie die ganze Zeit abdecken.
Zu seiner Arbeit als Hüttenwart
gehört es auch,
den Zustiegsweg durch das
Gletscher-Labyrinth zu unterhalten.
Am Nachmittag kontrollieren
Richard Lehner und Kilian Emmenegger,
ob die Markierungen
versetzt werden müssen.
Jetzt gehen wir dorthin.
Wir hacken das Eis hier ab.
Unten ist es fast zu breit.
Dort ist es fast zu breit.
Wenn wir es oben
noch etwas höher schaffen ...
Es hat sich
ziemlich stark verändert.
Ich war vor einer Woche hier
und der Spalt hat sich
um 20-30 cm vergrössert.
Ja, er ist breiter geworden.
- Dort, wo Kili ist.
Der Gletscher fliesst natürlich.
Dort, wo der Gletscher
in Wegrichtung fliesst,
wird alles mitgeschoben.
Aber dort, wo der Weg
quer durch den Gletscher führt,
schiebt der Gletscher
den Weg nach unten.
Daher müssen wir die Markierungen
immer wieder nach oben versetzen.
So auch bei dieser Spalte,
die inzwischen so gross ist,
dass sie
fast nicht mehr passierbar ist.
Richard Lehner muss dafür sorgen,
dass nicht plötzlich auf dem
Gletscherweg Rettungen nötig werden.
* Schweres Atmen *
Mind. alle zehn Tage
setzen sie Wegmarkierungen neu -
als Orientierung für die Besucher.
Sie halten eigentlich gut, sie
verschmelzen mit dem Gletscher.
Aber bei Wind und Sturm
sind sie weg.
Soll ich dir die Hand geben?
- Ja, ja.
(Mann) Du kannst noch etwas ...
- Hoppala.
Perfekt.
- Vielen Dank.- Bitte schön.
Bis später.
Jedes Jahr wird das Eis weniger.
Wir sind jeden Tag hier,
um den Weg zu unterhalten,
und sehen jedes Jahr
einen riesigen Unterschied.
Der Gletscher geht zurück
und sinkt ab.
Es ist enorm, wie viele Meter
pro Jahr der Gletscher zurückgeht.
* Ruhige, perlende Musik *
Es wird Abend.
Fast alle Gäste sind angekommen,
nur zwei fehlen noch:
ein Sohn von Richard Lehner
und dessen Kollege.
Hey.
* Richard lacht. *
Cool, tschau.
- Tschau.
Wie geht's?
- Gut.- War es cool?
Ja.
3 Std. 15 Min.
- 3 Std. 15 Min.? Vom Grünsee?
Wenigstens nicht so heiss.
- Aber ihr wart total schnell.
Das Wandern tut ihnen gut.
Sie sind wie Gämsen.
Eine freudige Überraschung.
- Ja, er sagte mir, dass er kommt.
Geht duschen,
dann gibt's Abendessen.- Gut.
Tschau.
- Tschüss.
Heute Nachmittag sagte er plötzlich,
dass er mich besuchen komme.
Ich sagte: "Ja, aber ..."
Er muss morgen ja arbeiten.
Er sagte: "Das geht schon."
Dann rannte er einfach los.
Sie wollten eigentlich
schon heute Abend wieder runter,
aber nun gehen sie
morgen um 5 Uhr los.
80 Abendessen
müssen heute zubereitet werden.
Richard Lehner hat früher
die Gandegghütte in Zermatt geführt.
Dort ist sein Sohn Arnaud
aufgewachsen.
Dieser weiss heute noch,
wo und wie angepackt werden muss.
Wir halfen in der Hütte
immer beim Abräumen mit.
In der Küche weniger,
dafür waren wir noch zu klein.
Aber im Service
halfen wir immer mit.
Ich koste mal die Suppe.
Super, tipptopp.
Abend auf der Monte Rosa Hütte,
Rettungen gab es keine mehr heute.
Er ist hinter dem Stein.
- Hinter dem Stein?
* Verträumte Klänge *
Am nächsten Tag: Die ersten Besucher
verlassen die Hütte.
Richard Lehner
hat bereits einen neuen Einsatz.
Die Information aus Zermatt:
Wanderer wollen evakuiert werden.
Sie können
anscheinend nicht mehr weiter.
Sie seien auf der Höhe
der Schönbielhütte,
gegenüber vom Stockji.
Wir schauen mal.
Sie sind genau auf 12 Uhr,
dort unten. Siehst du sie?- Jawohl.
Mit dabei auch ein Bergführer.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier.
Die vier, die rechts bzw. links von
ihnen sind, sollen evakuiert werden.
Links und rechts aussteigen.
- Okay, links und rechts aussteigen.
Die vier wollen die Tour,
die sog. Haute Route, abbrechen
und mit dem Helikopter
ausgeflogen werden.
Gehst du mit?
- Ich gehe mit den ersten dreien ...
Und ich bringe die anderen zwei.
(Englisch) Wenn der Helikopter
kommt, steigst du langsam ein.
Okay.
- Okay?
Wie geht's?
- Gut, vielen Dank.
Müde?
- Ja, mental und körperlich.
Wir haben
nicht viele Berge in Brasilien.
Ah, du bist aus Brasilien?
Auch solche Taxi-Flüge
gehören zum Rettungsalltag.
5 Min. Heliflug nach Zermatt
statt einer stundenlangen Wanderung.
Sog. Blockierungen -
Einsätze, ohne dass
ein medizinischer Notfall vorliegt -
machen heute bis zu einem Drittel
der Rettungen aus.
Den vier Wanderern geht es gut, aber
sie haben die Tour wohl unterschätzt.
To see the helicopter coming
was a bit ...
Wir sind um 5 Uhr losgewandert -
runter zum Gletscher,
wieder hoch zum Berg -
Tête Blanche -,
wieder runter
zum nächsten Gletscher.
Offenbar ist der Originalweg
nicht mehr begehbar.
Das wusstet ihr nicht?
Es war härter,
als wir erwartet haben.
Wir hätten nochmals weit hochmüssen,
das wäre sehr anstrengend geworden.
Etwa 700 Fr. pro Kopf
wird sie der Rettungsflug kosten.
Noch ist unklar, ob eine Versicherung
diesen Betrag übernehmen wird.
Wie geht's? Alles gut?
- Ja, danke.
Es war der sicherste Weg zurück
und die beste Art,
um die Tour abzuschliessen.
Danke.
Thank you very much, bye-bye.
- Wieder ein Einsatz abgeschlossen.
Nicht nur bei der Air Zermatt,
sondern schweizweit
haben in den letzten Jahren
die Rettungen zugenommen.
Das fällt auch
den beiden Bergrettern auf.
Die Gesellschaft ist schon ...
... einfacher geworden.
Wie nennt man das?
Gemütlicher.
- ... gemütlicher geworden.
Hat das auf eure Motivation
keinen Einfluss?
Nein, wenn sie uns um Hilfe bitten,
setzen wir alles daran,
ihnen zu helfen.
Unter der Voraussetzung,
dass wir unsere Sicherheit
gewährleisten können.
Aber dann geben wir schon Gas.
Den Leuten zu helfen,
ist schon unser Ziel.
Denken sie als Retter
manchmal auch daran,
dass etwas schiefgehen könnte?
Während des Einsatzes?
- Nein. Dafür haben wir keine Zeit.
Wir haben keine Zeit.
Es ist so wie beim Bergsteigen:
Man denkt nicht daran,
dass einem etwas passieren könnte.
Man ist ja von sich und seinen
Fähigkeiten überzeugt und denkt,
dass man
gutes Risikomanagement betreibt
und seine Grenzen kennt.
* Lebhafte Musik *
Nur selten
hat Richard Lehner im Sommer Zeit,
um mit seiner Familie
etwas zu unternehmen.
Heute geht's auf eine Biketour mit
den beiden Söhnen Arnaud und Xavier.
Beide sind hier aufgewachsen
und machen eine Lehre im Dorf -
der eine bei einem Zimmermann
und der andere in einem Hotel.
Wegziehen
käme für sie nicht infrage.
Da wir schon früher Hütten führten,
waren sie eigentlich den ganzen
Sommer über mit uns in der Hütte
und spielten und beschäftigten sich
den ganzen Tag draussen.
Das war super.
Wir durften machen, was wir wollten,
auch wenn wir Unsinn trieben.
Und abends mussten wir euch suchen.
Ihr wart den ganzen Tag unterwegs
und abends ...
Als es dunkel wurde,
kamen wir schon nach Hause.
Ja, als es dunkel wurde.
Es ist ein riesiger Spielplatz.
Es ist eine ganz andere Art
des Aufwachsens,
wenn man so viel Zeit
in den Bergen verbringt
und sich mit Steinen
und anderen einfachen Dingen
zufriedengeben muss.
Ein sommerlicher Kälteeinbruch - auch
das gehört zum Leben in den Bergen.
Wir müssen einfach aufpassen,
wenn Schnee liegt
und die Steine nass sind.
Ja, wenn es rutschig ist.
Auf Bergtouren
hat der Vater noch das Kommando.
Auf dem Bike sind die Söhne voraus.
Mit dem Bergretter-Job des Vaters
ist die Familie aufgewachsen.
Ich versuche schon,
nicht so an meine Grenzen zu gehen,
dass es gegenüber
den Daheimgebliebenen
unverantwortlich wäre.
Das habe ich immer
ein bisschen im Hinterkopf.
Früher kriegten wir
nicht viel davon mit,
da wir noch Kinder waren.
Aber heute interessiert es
uns schon, wo er war und ...
... was passiert ...
- ... ob etwas Schlimmes passierte.
Ja, also ...
Das ist etwas, was immer da war.
Als der Helikopter früher vor
dem Haus landete und Papa abholte,
fanden wir das
schon als kleine Kinder cool.
Eine gewisse Gefahr
besteht natürlich immer,
aber Papa macht das sehr gut.
Er hat viel Erfahrung.
Wenn etwas ist, ruft er uns an.
Nach der Rettung
ruft er auch gleich zu Hause an,
damit wir wissen,
dass alles okay ist.
Per Funk können wir das Ganze
meistens auch mitverfolgen.
Daher haben wir
schon Vertrauen in ihn.
Ich mache mir schon auch Sorgen,
da sie immer öfter
selbstständig unterwegs sind.
Da ich viele Rettungen durchführe,
kenne ich die Gefahren und weiss,
was alles passieren kann.
Den Rettungsjob wegen der Familie
aufzugeben war kein Thema.
Am nächsten Tag ist Richard Lehner
in der Hütte
bereits um 1.30 Uhr auf den Beinen:
Frühstück für die Bergsteiger.
Ich habe 3 Std. geschlafen, aber
später lege ich mich nochmals hin.
Man steht einfach auf. Das ist ...
Man weiss, dass man aufstehen muss
und dass die Leute auf einen zählen.
Daher tut man es einfach.
Aber es ist nicht so,
dass man gern aufsteht.
Ich glaube, das macht
um diese Zeit niemand wirklich gern.
Er und Kilian wechseln sich
mit den Morgenschichten ab,
sodass der Tag für die Angestellten
nicht zu lang wird.
Wie jeden Tag checkt er
am Morgen früh das Wetter.
Wenn die Leute aufstehen
und es leicht schneit,
herrscht immer
eine gewisse Unsicherheit.
Dann ist es praktisch ...
... wenn ich auch
eine Meinung zum Wetter habe.
Der Wind weht
auf 4'000 m ü.M. mit 50-60 km/h.
Er ist also ziemlich stark.
Das mache ich auch,
wenn ich Pikettdienst habe,
damit ich weiss,
was auf mich zukommt,
ob es ein Gewitter gibt etc.
Morgen.
- (Mann) Morgen.
Wie geht's?
Es scheint geschneit zu haben.
- Ja, ein bisschen Neuschnee.
Es schneit noch ganz leicht.
- Mal gucken, wie der Fels ist.
Ja.- Mal schauen.
Aber erst mal geht es gut.
Das ist die Hauptsache.
Es ist alles bereit.
Normalerweise sind
die Bergsteiger zu zweit unterwegs.
Dieser geht heute
jedoch alleine los.
Was ist dein Plan für heute?
- Ich steige auf die Dufourspitze.
Trotz Schnee?
Mal gucken, wie weit ich komme.
Die Dufourspitze
ist der höchste Berg der Schweiz.
Ich habe gestern
schon mit ihm gesprochen.
Er hat in der Hütte noch
nach einem Kletterpartner gesucht.
Ich sagte ihm, dass es nicht
empfehlenswert ist, allein zu gehen.
Aber er ist erwachsen.
Ich kann ihn nicht hier anbinden.
Die Berge hier in der Umgebung
sollte man nicht allein besteigen,
weil es überall gletschertechnische
Herausforderungen gibt.
Das ist wirklich nicht zu empfehlen.
Gestern schon
hat er den ersten Teil der Route
über einen Gletscher
ausgekundschaftet
und fühlt sich gut vorbereitet.
Es kam noch 1 cm Neuschnee hinzu,
aber das ändert nichts
an der Spaltensituation.
Ich bin bereits
durch den Eisbruch gegangen,
das ist eigentlich
das Gefährlichste.
Wenn man das kann, ist
der Rest auch nicht mehr schlimm.
Ich habe eine Notruf-App
auf dem Handy.
Die funktioniert,
sofern Empfang vorhanden ist.
Ich habe auch
dem Hüttenwart Bescheid gesagt,
wann ich wieder da bin.
Also,
ich minimiere schon das Risiko.
Und ich bin auch schon
seit 20 Jahren dabei.
Gegen 2.30 Uhr
starten die Seilschaften.
Trotz kalten und stürmischen
Bedingungen, die vorausgesagt sind -
und das Anfang August.
Vom Matterhorn bis rüber
zum Zinalrothorn ist schon alles zu.
Hier oben sieht es
noch nicht so schlecht aus,
es ist einfach windig.
Ich brauche das
nicht mehr jeden Tag,
aber wenn die Leute
morgens aufbrechen,
denke ich manchmal schon,
dass es schön wäre, mitzugehen.
Andererseits ist es auch schön,
dass ich mich nun noch
für 1-2 Std. hinlegen kann.
Ja.
* Erhabene, donnernde Klänge *
Schon im Verlauf des Morgens:
Böenspitzen von bis zu 100 km/h.
Dann um 10.30 Uhr ein Notruf.
Siehst du mich, Gerold?
Rechts von dir.
Beim Pollux ist jemand ein Stück
hinuntergestürzt, ein Absturz.
Die Italiener versuchten schon ran-
zukommen, schafften es aber nicht.
U.U. müssen wir versuchen, die
Person terrestrisch zu erreichen.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
An Bord: Pilot Gerold Biner
und ein zweiter Retter.
(Mann über Funk)
Ich starte geradeaus.
Die Retter wissen nicht,
was sie erwartet.
Ihre einzige Information:
Der Verletzte ist auf der Rückseite
der eisbedeckten Kuppe
in der Südostwand des Pollux,
am Zwillingsjoch.
Zwei Bergsteiger seien abseits
der normalen Route unterwegs gewesen.
Ich nehme an, dass er von dieser
Ecke hinten runtergefallen ist.
Noch hat die Crew
die Opfer nicht entdeckt.
* Spannungsvolle Klänge *
Challenging, was?
Es sind schwierige Windverhältnisse.
Der Rettungskollege
und Richard Lehner steigen aus,
um sich ans Seil anzuhängen
und in die Nähe der Unfallstelle
geflogen zu werden.
* Unverständlicher Funkspruch *
Tipptopp, los geht's.
Wir versuchen es mal.
Sagt mir, wie viele Meter
es ungefähr sind.- 50.
30.
- Wie hoch ist die Leistung?
75.
1 m.
- (Frau) 75.
Alfa, Kontakt.
Langsam entlasten.
Der Heli setzt sie
auf dem Gipfelgrat des Pollux ab,
wo auch andere Bergsteiger
unterwegs sind.
Das Seil ist frei.
- 70.
Ihr müsst jetzt wahrscheinlich ...
Richi, hier vorn unten.
Irgendwo da unten im Geröll
muss das Opfer liegen.
Wir klettern
über die Kette nach unten.
Hier oben weht Nordwestwind.
Jawohl.
Die Retter versuchen, die
Unfallstelle zu Fuss zu erreichen.
Sie wissen nicht,
in welchem Zustand das Opfer ist.
Wir müssen darauf achten,
nicht zu viel Zeit zu vergeuden,
damit wir reagieren können,
wenn Richi den Arzt braucht.
Am Heli-Landeplatz
der Monte Rosa Hütte
wartet Arzt Michael Krappitz
auf seinen Einsatz.
Zuerst muss man den Patienten
erreichen und schauen,
wie man im Gelände zurechtkommt
und wie die Verhältnisse sind.
Dann komme ich ins Spiel.
Am Pollux haben unterdessen
die beiden Retter das Opfer erreicht.
Wie geht es ihm?
Einer der Bergsteiger
hat einen Felsblock ausgerissen
und ist abgestürzt.
Wie viele Meter ist er abgestürzt?
Der Erste
hat den Zweiten mitgerissen.
Sie stürzten etwa 60 m ab.
Einer ist schwer verletzt.
Zwei Bergführer sind bei ihm.
(Mann) Männlich,
60 Jahre, Kopfplatzwunde
und eine Wunde an den Rippen,
an der rechten Seite.
(Englisch) Wie geht es dir?
Ich bin von der Bergrettung.
(Französisch) Was ist passiert?
Der Mann erzählt, beide
seien gestürzt. Auch sein Partner.
Dir geht's gut?
- Alles gut.
Wir brauchen den Arzt
und eine Vakuummatratze.
Das Opfer blutet stark am Kopf.
Geht's? Bleib bei uns.
Sie hatten riesiges Glück, dass sie
nicht ganz hinuntergestürzt sind.
Er hat ihn richtig festgehalten.
Er war schon ...
- Schon über der Kante.
Unten auf der Monte Rosa Hütte
hat sich der Arzt inzwischen an
einer 100 m langen Leine eingehängt
und wird von Pilot Gerold Biner
zur Absturzstelle geflogen.
Der Pilot benötigt diese Länge,
um mit dem Heli über der Gratkante
schweben zu können.
Alles klar bei dir?
(Krappitz) Ja, alles klar.
Wir umrunden den Berg von vorn.
Dann sinken wir hinten wieder ab.
So sollten wir ungefähr dieselbe
Höhe haben wie diese Spitze.
So bist du sicher
über der hinteren Spitze, okay?
Ja.
Eine Person an einer so langen Leine
bei Wind von 100 km/h
metergenau in einer Wand absetzen:
für alle eine Herausforderung.
Okay.
Gerold Biner
sieht den Arzt nicht mehr genau,
er braucht die Höhe per Funk.
Michael, wie hoch
über dem Boden bist du?
Etwa 50 m.
Jetzt ist er
etwa 30 m vom Boden entfernt.
Michael, jetzt musst du mir die Höhe
angeben - alle 5 Sek., bitte.
Der Bergführer
ist etwa 10 m unter mir.
Okay.- Beim Geröll sieht es
nicht schlecht aus zum Landen.
(Frau) 95 ...
... 90 ...
- (Richard) Kontakt.
Es hat geklappt.
Der Arzt ist beim Patienten.
Komm hier rein.
(Krappitz) Bonjour.
Ich bin der Arzt.
Ich gebe dir jetzt ein
Schmerzmittel, das auch müde macht.
Jetzt müssen sie den Patienten
in die Vakuummatratze heben.
Achtung, er hat ziemliche Schmerzen.
Achtung, eins, zwei, drei.
So, gut.
Wir schliessen es hier,
damit er warm kriegt.
Der Wind ist inzwischen so stark,
dass die Leine
bei der Monte Rosa Hütte
von 100 auf 130 m
verlängert werden muss,
damit der Patient
sicher ausgeflogen werden kann.
Wenn wir Glück haben, können wir den
Arzt und den Patienten mitnehmen,
aber bei diesem Wind
und mit so langen Leinen
ist das nicht so lustig.
Die italienischen Kollegen
hatten zuvor die Rettung aufgegeben.
Gerold Biner
will es trotzdem versuchen.
Inzwischen dauert
die Rettung schon fast 2 Std.
Wir sind genau an der Kante,
wo es so extrem windet.
Jetzt würde die Richtung stimmen.
70.
- Zwei ab, Höhe okay.
80.
- Einer ab, Kontakt.
Auf drei.
Auf zwei.
- 75.
85.
- Er ist in der Luft.
Ging es bei dir, Gerold?
Ja, es ging gerade so.
Der Verletzte wird nun mit dem Arzt
zu einer tiefer gelegenen Hütte
geflogen.
Von dort bringen ihn
die italienischen Kollegen
ins Spital nach Aosta.
Jetzt müssen noch
der zweite Verletzte
und die Retter geholt werden.
Doch der Wind hat weiter zugenommen.
Auf welcher Höhe bin ich?
75.
Wir sind auf 5 m.
Zwei sind bereit.
4 m ...
... 8 ...
4 m ab, 3 m und stopp.
Es geht nicht, Richi.
Es ist zu windig.
Dann steigen wir ab, Gerold.
Okay, dann steigt ihr ab.
Ich kehre zur Hütte zurück
und nehme das Seil ab.
Das ist gut. Wir steigen ab.
Ça va pour marcher?
- Oui, oui, ça va.
Der zweite Mann ist am Bein verletzt.
Trotzdem muss er zu Fuss runter.
Super.
* Emotionale Klänge *
Bei der Monte Rosa Hütte
trifft inzwischen
der einzelne Bergsteiger ein,
der am Morgen
zur Dufourspitze aufgebrochen ist.
Hey, wie war's?
- Kalt.
Hast du's geschafft?
- Ja, ich war oben.
Aber?
- Nichts aber, ich war oben.
Und auf dem Gipfel stürmte es.
Es war richtig kalt.
Es war alles gefroren.
Aber du kamst heil wieder runter.
- Ich habe keine Schramme.
Alles gut gegangen.
Weit unten - auf 2'000 m -
nimmt unterdessen
der italienische Rettungshelikopter
den zweiten Verletzten in Empfang.
Für Richard Lehner
als Rettungsspezialisten
geht ein langer Tag zu Ende.
So, seid ihr alle angeschnallt?
Ging es, Richi?
- Ja.
Gut, tipptopp.
Es war nicht einfach.
Das war einfach ein Scheissort.
Siehst du,
da unten im Couloir lag er.
Ist nicht gerade hübsch dort.
Gut, es hat alles gut geklappt,
alles erledigt.
Tipptopp. Das war ein super Job.
Super gearbeitet, Richi.
- Ich danke dir.
Über 5 Std.
war Richard Lehner unterwegs.
Zum Glück
habe ich ausgiebig gefrühstückt.
Du siehst etwas mitgenommen aus.
- Ja?
Ja. War es schlimm?
Es war v.a. kalt.
Kalt, windig und ...
... nicht ganz einfach.
Es war sehr,
sehr, sehr anspruchsvoll.
Weswegen?
- Wegen des Windes.
Die Windgeschwindigkeit
betrug 80-100 km/h, böig.
Dort hinten,
wo sie waren, riss er ab.
Es ist sehr gefährlich,
wenn man in den Bereich gerät,
wo Abwind herrscht.
Dann kann man
den Helikopter nicht mehr halten.
Der Unfallort
war an einer so blöden Stelle,
dass man einfach
keinen Fehler machen durfte.
* Muntere, perlende Musik *
Auf 30-40 Bergeinsätze kommt
Richard Lehner als Retter pro Jahr.
Das war einer der anspruchsvolleren.
Er ist froh, dass es mit
der Helikopterrettung geklappt hat.
Zu Fuss - sog. terrestrisch -
hätte die Bergung
bis in die Nacht hinein gedauert.
Wenn wir ihn terrestrisch
hätten retten müssen,
wäre es wegen der Temperaturen,
wegen des starken Windes etc.
irgendwann zu einem Rennen
gegen die Zeit geworden,
um ihn noch lebend rauszukriegen.
Von den Geretteten hören
die Retter selten ein Dankeswort.
Auch in diesem Fall.
Wir machen unsere Arbeit
und dann ist es für uns ...
Wir kriegen auch selten
eine Rückmeldung von den Gästen.
Wir erledigen unsere Arbeit
einfach so gut wie möglich.
Es gibt einem schon
eine gewisse Befriedigung,
wenn man merkt,
dass man gute Arbeit geleistet hat.
Wenn wir im Team unterwegs sind
und eine Rettung durchführen,
ohne die die Verunglückten
nicht überlebt hätten,
verschafft uns das schon
eine gewisse Befriedigung.